شكرا يا معانا في الاسود عبد القادر
دراماس اهلا بك عبد القادر عبد القادر
رعودتا
امس تحديدا من اوكرانيا هذه الحرب لعده
ايام ربما اللافت في هذه الايام الاخيره
التي كنت فيها في اوكرانيا هو الانقطاعات
المتكرره في الكهرباء وايضا في المياه لو
ربما نود ان نفهم معك وتطلعنا على تجربتكم
انتم كن صحفيين كيف يعيشون هذا الولد ايضا
عن همم معاناه السكان المحليه
على القصف على الخسائر الماديه والبشريه
لكن قلنا من يشيلون الى الماسات الانسانيه
التي يعيشون يعيشونها عفوا الاوكرانيون
نتذكر عند وصولنا الى العاصمه كيف تفاجات
شخصيا ظلام دامس لما يتوقع هذا الشيء كنت
اسمع على انقطاع التيار الكهربائي لكن
عاصمه اوكرانيا في هذا الظلام تفاجات
وصلنا حوالي الساعه الرابعه بتوقيت المحلي
هناك شاهد العديد من الاوكرانيين يستعملون
يستعمل من اجل الخروج في الحياء المصابيح
اليدويه العديد من العائلات خروجا من من
العمل حتى يدخلون الى منازلهم يستعملون
المصابيح اليدويه شاهد ايضا من العديد من
الاوكرانيين يلبسون البسه فيها فيها
اشارات عاكسه للضوء من اجل السيارات ظلام
دامس يخيف ولكن تتوقعي هذا الظلام الدامس
من جهه في هذا البرد القارس درجات الحراره
المتدنيا كلها تحت الصفر يعني بقينا لمده
اسبوعين لمده اسبوعين درجه الحراره بين
سته وسبعه تحت الصفر الامر مرعب مخيف يمكن
لقول ان الاوكرانيين منذ بدايه الحرب في
الرابع والعشرين في بدايه الغزو تعودوا
نوعا ما على صفيرات الانذار على القصف لكن
صعب جدا ان تتعايش وتتحمل هذا البرد وهذه
الحرب في في ضمن انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
الاوكرانيون لا يفكرون الا في تعبئه
هواتفهم اريد ان اقاسمك هذا الشيء كنا مع
صحفيه اوكرانيه بحكم انه تعمل معنا بحكم
الترجمه لانه اوكرانيه حتى تترجم تترجم
لنا التقارير الصحفيه المصوره هناك كانت
تختنم الفرصه كل ما تكون معنا في الفندق
من اجل تعبئه الهاتف
والبطاريه اليدويه سالتها قالت انني بدون
تيار كهربائي منذ اكثر من اسبوعين او
ثلاثه انقطع التيار الكهربائي في الصباح
بدون طيار بدون مياه لان القصف والطائرات
المسيره باتت تستهدف بسهوله كبيره البنيه
التحتيه وخاصه محطات توزيع وتوليد
الكهرباء والتصفيه المياه هناك ايضا رحله
اخرى يعاني منها الاوكرانيون هي رحله
البحث عن المولدات الكهربائيه بدون تيار
كهربائي لا بد من حتى تتعايش نوعا ما مع
مع الوضع لابد من مولد كهرباء الان باتا
الحصول على مولد كهربائي امرا صعبا جدا
همم كثره الطلب عليه تعقيدات الاسعار همم
همم اريد همم اقول لك عفوا انه لتر واحد
من البنزين يضمن ساعه فقط من التيار
الكهربائي للعائلات هناك تتخيل لعائله من
ثلاثه او اربعه اشخاص كل هذا بات امرا
مخيفا يعقد ويعكر حياه الاوكرانيين الان
في اوكرانيا لكنه ربما تبع هذه المهمه في
كل اوكرانيا تحديدا هو عوده الغارات بشكل
مكثف وتحديدا على العاصمه اكياس من داخل
اوكرانيا عبد القادر يعني كيف ينظر الى
الجبهات الاكثر اشتعالا وحتى ربما هل من
ترجيحات لشبهاء الجبهات اخرى قد تكون هي
الاكثر شعالا في الايام والاسابيع المقبله
شكرا عندما تتحدث معهم تفهم مباشره انهم
يتخوفون من بدايه العام الجديد يتوقعون
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه نشرت في اكثر
من مره في اكثر من بيان انها تتوقع عمليه
عسكريه ميدانيه جديده من الحدود البيضاء
الروسيه
الشمال من الشمال الخسيسه همم ذهبنا في
مهمه على بعد 10 كيلومترات فقط من الحدود
الروسيه المتاخمه لمدينه
خاركي في ثاني اكبر المدن الاوكرانيه
وهناك تحدث مع اكثر من عائله وتفاجئت
للمشاهد التي رايتها قريات ليست قريه
قريات مهجوره كليا قريات كانت فيها ثلاث
واربع الاف اربع و 5000 ساكن وهجرت كليه
لانها موجوده في ما يسمى بالمنطقه
الرماديه التي تكون موجوده بين القوات
الروسيه من جهه والقوات اوكرانيا من جهه
عند التجدد القصف الضحيه رقم واحد هي هذه
العائله هناك القصف بات عادي لكن مؤخرا
اصبح القسم المكثف همم قبل ثلاث ايام
القصف المكثف الذي استهدفها من منطقه
خيرسون في جنوبيه اوكرانيا
همم اصفر على خسائر بشريه كبيره جدا
بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من البناء الرئيس
همم الاوكراني فولوديمازينينسكي اتهمه
روسيا بارتيكا جريمه حرب جديده همم نفس
الامر في حركه التي تم استعاداتها في
سبتمبر الماضي خالك كيف تتعرض بشكل يومي
للقصف المدفعي والقصف بقضاء في الهاون على
المناطق المتخمه للحدود تحاول القوات
الروسيه في كل مره محاوله استرجاع المناطق
التي همم التي التي خرجت منها في الاونه
الاخيره في المدينه او في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اصبحت تستهدف بطائره مسيره من
نوع شاهد طائرات الدرون الايرانيه التي
اصبحت تستهدف في اكثر من مره وبيسهوله
بدقه محطه توزيع الكهرباء مما يتسبب في
هذا الظلام الدامس وهذه الماساه الانسانيه
التي بداتها يعيشها الاوكرانيون شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات تهتم لعبد
القادر كانك تعود للتو من تغطيه الحرب في
اوكرانيا